hi I'm Nick Gillespie with raisin TV and
today we're talking with Baylin Lynne
akin he's a longtime Reason columnist
and he is also a writer and food
activist and he's the author of the
excellent new book biting the hands that
feed us how fewer smarter laws would
make our food system more sustainable
balanced thanks for talking to us thanks
Nick let's talk a little bit about some
innovation killing laws or food stifling
laws you talk about a guy named Mark
denita's of a Colorado based Salumeria
called el mondo Vecchio what happened to
him so he had this sort of award-winning
Salumeria that he started after teaching
at Johnson the whales which is a leading
culinary school for ten years he taught
food safety courses he started this
Salumeria he was and that and that's a
place that makes traditionally cured
meats or dried meat yeah dried and cured
I think yeah both and so you know his he
was selling he was he won awards from
eater or anyone I think the Colorado
Restaurant Association is best new chef
making all these great products and he
was always USDA inspected he always
passed his USDA inspections he had all
this private inspections too and one day
the USDA inspector told him hey listen
you know you can't actually make this
anymore
because you're not adding nitrates or
nitrates to your food and so said either
you can do that or you can pay for a
challenge study which would cost
thousands of dollars and years you know
of results were needed to try to
continue doing what you're doing
or as Ginetta says you can just simply
go out of business because he had this
sort of old-world ethos you know his
company was called montevecchia which
means the old world and he really wanted
to do things like they were and nitrates
and nitrites are things I mean they're
additives that are not necessary but
they're used in commercial food
processing because they're easier and
they're cheaper right right and you know
plenty of artisanal producers use them
right nothing wrong with them per se
they're found in
green vegetables I think celery root is
high in but it should be someone's
choice as long as they're achieving good
out so that's an example of where the
USDA comes in and basically runs a guy
who is redefining old world
processes for willing customers in the
US then talk about you have a whole
chapter devoted to with the ways of
which mostly local laws banned food
donations from restaurants or kind of
big suppliers to homeless people are to
hungry people I know you've written
about that for us and elsewhere we cover
it from time to time what's going on
there yeah so it's actually the case
that most you know if you want to there
really aren't laws that prohibit you at
the state or federal level from giving
or even getting tax breaks for food
donations restaurants can generally give
food to say a food bank or a shelter if
they and so that's like at the end of a
night they have a bunch of food leftover
and so they'll give it to a local soup
kitchen right and there are actually are
good protections one of the good laws I
talked about in the book in place that
say if you're doing this then and you're
not doing you know you're not overtly
negligent or intentionally trying to
sicken someone then you're essentially
shielded from litigation but what
happens in places like New York City
Orlando Houston Dallas Las Vegas
Philadelphia lots of cities around the
country
lawmakers City Council's have passed
rules that say that you can't share food
with the homeless and less fortunate
people in Orlando have been arrested for
doing this and I think of all the laws
that I talk about in the book this one
is the most if you know what is the
rationale behind that because you know
so this is something where you could
take something from a four star
restaurant or whatever and it's like I
could we didn't sell all of the I don't
know the veal piccata or something we're
gonna give it to a local food bank and
then like who's gonna get in the way of
that so it's more about individual say
you want to you know you're you're part
of like a non-profit and in the case of
Orlando it's this group of Food Not
Bombs they're anti-war group that
believes that sharing food as part of
their mission and
my interview another guy J hamburger
he's based in Houston who's known as the
Eggman he's been giving eggs and and
other food to the homeless there he
sounds like a horrible human being
one of history's greatest monster
absolutely so the best and by best I
mean worst rationale ever given by
anyone not surprisingly was by Mayor
Bloomberg who said that you could not
donate food to city's shelters because
the city could not and you can almost
predict where this is going assess the
salt fat or nutrition content of the
food now it says there's no question
that the hungry throughout history have
been very insistent that you know it's a
low sodium hour hit bricks so why is
this happening now I mean that the
trends that you talk about in the books
or the cataloguing of just pretty insane
stupid laws that don't seem to pass kind
of a rational human being test or have
the outcomes that the crafters of these
laws pass why is this happening that why
is it growing now what's going on I mean
I think there's a growing pushback
against it and that's why I'm writing
about it that's why we're hearing more
about it we've got people in Congress
who actually are paying attention to
these issues
Masey representatives nasty and Pingree
you know sort of libertarian Republican
and a pretty lefty Democrat have both
sponsored some legislation run try to
push back against so it is I mean so the
kind of rationale to you know create
these laws that your title you know that
bite the hands that feed us that's kind
of a constant that's been going on yeah
I think I mean I trace things certainly
back to the New Deal era there was a
great time magazine article around the
time that Wickard V filburn was decided
which was also at the same time and
which was about a farmer who wanted to
grow some grain for personal use and
then that the Supreme Court ultimately
ruled that no actually there's really no
such thing as produce or crops grown for
personal use it's part of Interstate
Commerce and Congress has the right to
regulate it exactly and and so at that
same time that was when mrs. Roosevelt's
a First Lady Eleanor Roosevelt
was trying to establish Victory Garden
on the White House grounds and she
actually had to go to the USDA and get
permission because as time reported the
USDA was skeptical of amateur farmers
what are some of the good food rules
that you point out and how do you make
that the rule rather than the exception
so one good food roll that I talked
about is prohibition on unsustainable
foraging I talked about how I like to
forage for various you know fruits and
whatnot when I'm out hiking blackberries
things like that and there was a guy in
Maryland who was actually issued a fine
for picking some berries in a public
park that's a ridiculous where he found
to be ripping those you know blackberry
bushes out of the ground that's that's
not sustainable foraging and so that's
you know where the the prohibition would
come in but I mean blackberries as I
recount in the book they want you to
pick them the blackberries do the black
dirt you're talking to the blackberries
you'd know what blackberries thick
absolutely okay you also you mentioned I
mean one of the highlights of the book
is Wyoming's 2015 food Freedom Act as a
kind of model do you want to talk about
that yeah sure so there's a state rep
there Tyler Lindhome who worked with
he's a Republican he worked with
Democrats I think this law actually
passed through the Senate in the state
with a unanimous approval and it
basically expanded the state's cottage
fruit law and cottage food laws are
things that allow sort of local
production of what are known as non
potentially hazardous foods do you think
that the pushback that you talk about
that you document in the book and
frankly that you're trying to pour
gasoline on right I mean you you want
pushback against laws that restrict are
what you call food freedom our ability
to basically make and consume whatever
we want to eat or drink is that is the
pushback partly coming because we're all
artisanal eaters and we're all artisanal
chefs now I mean I think there's a
disconnect amongst some of the sort of
foodie types who you know some wants or
this immaculate and perfect food safety
which is a been unachievable and frankly
unnecessary goal and others want the
success
and the flourish meant of local food and
those are sort of at loggerheads there
at odds they're not going to work and
you know those are sort of lefties and
then people on the rights plenty of them
are interested in local food but they're
skeptical of sustainability is something
that oh this you know it's just these
people who want more regulations and so
I'm trying to sort of talk to both
groups and who I think talk past each
other a lot and say hey listen you guys
want some of the same outcomes let's
find out a way to do this I mean the the
kind of food deregulation issue and then
the enabling of artisanal or an
innovative prep both old old-school
practices and new-school practices and
innovative practices is one place where
a kind of libertarian perspective is
actually right in the middle yeah I
think so I mean I think that the
extremists are the ones who either want
to continue to subsidize be a gag or who
you know want to completely regulate
food safety in such a way that it makes
sure that we can't actually eat anything
beyond distilled water all right well we
will leave it there we have been talking
with Balin linic in he is a reason
columnist he's a lawyer on food issues
as well as a food activists of food
freedom activists and he's the author
most recently lived the excellent new
book biting the hands that feed us how
fewer smarter laws would make our food
system more sustainable Valen thanks for
talking to us thank you Nick
for Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie